Lilly Anderson I'm Team Coco Digital my
favorite videos coming your way after I
do a solo the first video is the
apparently kid I've never been alive
television before and believe it or not
I was a little redhead just like that
and I talked like that but I was a
little heavier I've really sometimes I
don't watch - I don't watch the news
because I'm a kid in a pearl every time
brilliant boy butters gives me a run on
out don't you watch the Powerball you're
gonna love this video yeah no probably
ones down the super slide scared half to
death I just freaked out
hey does anybody know who this baby
belongs to it just showed up here it's a
little creepy anyway no this is an honor
of charlie bit my finger remember that
one and it reminds me of me and my
little brother Tommy I'm sure I bit his
finger but still this is hilarious this
is our last video and it's a doozy there
are over 10 million Millennials out
there who have graduated with a work
ethic
no job no discernible skills at all and
they have expenses I had no idea that
Millennials were suffering
I am aspiring photographer I graduated
college with an art degree so obviously
that puts me at a disadvantage
Volkswagen Jetta leaves beard wax
Spotify Premium this is millennial
international take a look you'll be
shocked join me in sponsoring a
millennial today and help us help us
help us help us live the lives we
portray on Instagram
[Music]
well that's our last video I hope you
had fun I know I did
Louie Anderson on everything you can get
a hold of me I love you guys have a
great day
I've never ever been once over I never
ever wanted